hello freak [ __ ] and then dealing
with the fallout yeah I used to have to
deal with a lot more I used to choose to
deal with a lot more and now it's just
like I'm 46 like I don't know what to
tell you like there was a person who
came to one of the screenings on the
road we had the screening at pocket
forget where we were once in New Orleans
and of yoga hoses I was doing Q&A
afterwards and you know one's getting up
and like aunts bonds [ __ ] stupid and
asking questions and then one guy gets
up and he is like tight dude he's very
serious and he's just like okay you told
a big long story before that movie began
and I did it was a big intro for the
movement again so like an hour-long
story of how we got there and he goes
that story did not match the movie I
just watched and I said no and he goes
not at all and he goes why did you make
that movie he's going I found that
unwatchable I can dive when the audience
is going oh and I was like now many he
paid like he overpaid to see this movie
if I'm sitting there talking so yeah let
him say what do you want like I'm a big
boy I'm fine until he goes I just don't
think you ever should have made it it's
terrible and I said well you understand
that subjective right like you're
surrounded by a bunch people that feel
like the opposite way so you know people
were bought in [ __ ] and then some guy
behind him in line jumps in front of
Mike and goes you want me to kick his
ass and I was like holy [ __ ] no I was
like everyone's entitled to their
opinion I said but his opinion is I
never should have done this and my
answer to that is like that's ridiculous
like if I wanted to make it like that's
the only reason we're here I just want
to see it like you could choose not to
see it and in this instance I'm really
sorry that like you didn't our taste
didn't coincide but every time I go to
do one of these things I do it the same
way whether it was clerks up to the most
recent one I just make the movie I want
to see and hopefully others like it and
sometimes they do and that's amazing it
feels great you're like holy [ __ ] my
fingers on the post and sometimes you're
[ __ ] alone but at least you're like
I'm happy with the thing that I made I
said but I feel heartbroken that you
came out of here looking for something I
didn't give you so I said I'm gonna
giving your money back and I gave pulled
up 40 bucks and I was like put it on the
there's like a riser speaker and he goes
I don't want that and I was like no man
honestly take it's not a trick it's not
like Jason Mewes gonna come out hit you
with
hammer just take it like I feel bad I
want you to have a good time and [ __ ]
like that because no I want that and I
was like dude it makes for an excellent
story like I'd be like I told him is
movie [ __ ] blue to his face and I
[ __ ] took his money and walked out
and he goes now and he went and sat down
and crossed his arms and just stayed
there for another like half hour during
the Q&A so for him it was worth the 40
bucks to say it I'm gonna vision I'm
burbles like just sit here and [ __ ]
hate on this and let you know and then
sit down again so you know you deal with
that but that's the memorable one
because that never happens generally
speaking like when we toured the movie
you're touring in it you're in a safe
zone it's like going out on and doing a
club night it's like eating people there
are there because they love you they're
not going wonder if this [ __ ] tween
sausage movie is for me like they're
already dialed in on some part of the
journey like oh I've loved Tosk or I've
been with them since clerks or so forth
and so on
[Applause]
[Music]